[Music]
foreign
he's using his jacket as some kind of
security blanket that's so cute and
pathetic it really is you do you weirdo
oh hey guys I'm just sucking on my
jacket a clump of Honey candy got stuck
right there over a thousand years ago
and I can still taste it you know who I
bet would like some of that me zeitberg
oh no
seidberg you residue hog now all I taste
is crab juice so buy another jacket
candy I can't they stopped making it
after it got reclassified as industrial
glue ah then I Bender will recreate the
recipe don't forget I came in third I'm
MasterChef Junior
may I have a taste sure you seem like
the kind of guy who has a mouth
whoa whoa diabetic coma
hmm I better add some sugar to make it
less sweet
and just a touch of treacle to remind me
of my dear departed Aunt Juanita
she drowned in treacle you know I'm
dying on the floor
foreign
[Music]